hi Josh galperin associate director of
the Yale Center for Environmental Law
and Policy and I was also in professor
Nolan's um class a few years ago and
graduate with your daughter here from
FES but my question has nothing to do
with that I actually wanna follow up on
the the the anarchy concern I'm a little
concerned not so much about anarchy
itself but the perception of anarchy so
my question is we've got this whirlwind
of of economic social and state and
local regulatory activity and I think
that does create this perception of
anarchy and a hundred years ago when
this happened with coal in Pennsylvania
it really marked a watershed moment in
in regulatory law in and land use law
because the Supreme Court got involved
and saw this same sort of these same
forces coming together and I think was
nervous about this potential of a gnat
regulatory anarchy and it marked a major
change so I'm wondering if you see that
same potential now if we had pen coal
100 years ago and if we're looking at
Penn gas now that's a very interesting
comment the pen call case the Supreme
Court said that taking that supportive
state away by regulation under
Pennsylvania law was a regulatory taking
and had to be compensated and I think
you're dead-on I think that's exactly
one of the issues we've got all that all
that resource underground it's owned by
the people in New York who owned this
who owned the surface they're leasing
their land to drilling companies and
they have to be allowed to do that you
can't just take that away it has to if
you're going to limit it has to be a
reasonable set of regulations and what
the court pointed out and then Cole is
that what they did was not reasonable so
I think that that it's interesting I
just wanted to make an anecdotal comment
we have a town Stanford in New York that
just van talking about fracking these
town officials said we've got things to
do we run our towns and we have town
board maze and all you people want to
talk about is fracking enough unless
something is on the agenda you can't
talk about fracking
I mean talk about anarchy this is in a
recent poll showed that forty percent of
the people in New York think fracking is
great and forty percent think it's
terrible the other twenty percent are
undecided I mean this is really a very
very difficult issue and I think your
point of reason is another good one to
remember there are right there are
judicial consequences to unreasonable
action